let's go to the phones a couple of days
early we are off on Thursday and Friday
for Thanksgiving so we are taking calls
today we take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord and we're working through some
technical issues and let's see if we can
do it let's go first to Toby from North
Carolina Toby if you can hear me and if
you're unmuted let me know what's on
your mind today
uh hi David can you hear me I can hear
you fine
hi so um recently with the
um shooting in Colorado
um at what point do you think we should
start holding people
um accountable for
the hateful rhetoric surrounding uh gay
people and trans people and other
marginalized groups because it seems
like you could draw a pretty direct line
between uh violence and um these
people's rhetoric well listen morally
speaking I think it's pretty clear that
there is already what we might call
responsibility and in fact we did a
segment
um earlier about how they're going
pretty quickly to the victim blaming and
saying listen these groomers should
expect what's going on because of gender
affirming care and so on and so forth so
morally speaking we're already there
legally speaking we're really kind of
talking about a type of stochastic
terrorism
and it we've talked before about how it
is really difficult to hold people
legally responsible when you have an
audience of you know 5 million and you
target some individual or a group and
then one person goes and does something
I'm not saying anyone specifically said
go and do this at this particular place
but when someone goes and does something
legally speaking you're not really going
to be able to hold them accountable
based on current law and I don't even
know exactly what a better law would
look like I'm just not weighing in but I
just don't think you're really going to
be able to
all right that's all I got thank you all
right Toby from North Carolina thank you
very much appreciate hearing from you if
you have a friend or loved one who is
passionate about the environment here is
a perfect holiday gift our sponsor
established titles is a project that
lets you ceremonially purchase as little
as one square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or a lady like the
historic Scottish tradition some people
even change their plane tickets or
credit cards to include Lord or lady
your title pack comes with an official
certificate you can see exactly where
your plot of land is located it makes a
perfect last minute gift but most
importantly established titles plants
one free tree for every plot of land
sold established titles does really good
work all over the world with
reforestation organizations like one
tree planted and trees for the future so
you'll have a great laugh whether you're
Scottish or not I'm not but you're
giving the gift of reforestation to
fight climate change if you use my link
you'll get 10 off and your plot of land
will be right next to mine you can see
it on a map go to establishtitles.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman for an
extra 10 off on top of their Black
Friday deal the link is down below